hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay we
just went into this house from a
cemetery so you know things are gonna be
great quite wah wah Oh
[Music]
mmm oh this whole place is unsettling
I don't like this at all I definitely do
not like this okay III - the other one
was oh one six I remember that III - oh
one six oh one six three two emblem of a
yellow god is carved into the lock that
although I own six III - I think I don't
know yellow God again well Wow all right
yeah no oh yeah phone yeah I'll try it
nope oh one more huh Oh smashed you to
bits
I like this fire axe first good melee
weapon I've got I mean the hammer was
okay but way too slow ah ah get back get
back get back
punky okay oh oh you swinging at the
ground to the ground
yeah alright something about a yellow
god 163 III - oh hello oh ah ah I'm on
bed ha ha ha oh that's so sad for you
what was that oh come on oh come on wait
where am i oh ok I've already killed
them look at all that blood on the walls
okay there's a guy come here Cooper yeah
that's right just come closer
there we go man it's quick I like it
oh man that guy was tough too anyway
revolver whoa
is that like replace the desert eagle I
don't even know where the doesn't go oh
it's over there
I'm gonna Kohli Hill I don't know I'm it
has fewer bullets so is it more powerful
than the desert eagle that would be
something whoa well hello like uh huh
how about that I was weird
ah I'm giving it to you I thought it at
first I thought it was gonna say I'm
going to get you and I was like oh no
okay that's fine let's see what the fire
axe for now hello hello it's privacy
screen okey
Oh a key to that door Oh yellow God key
okay alright that makes sense
anything in there ah ah Amer mrow
I love me some AMRO yeah I still I'm
still disappointed that I didn't get
that gun before but whatever it's all
good this one's more powerful anyway or
so I think
huh it's red in here oh oh whoa oh oh
that picture gives me shivers oh my god
I'm a clone eyes you all look at it Oh
Oh down there oh man
startled me I'll revolver ammo I like it
the revolver was like the ultimate gun
in half alive oh you can just use the
doors to get the battery to get the
doors open okay that's good yeah let me
find out what's on the other side you're
probably another Brown Damon ah Brown
Damon must be Matt Damon's older uglier
brother ah oh oh there any place I can
get you closer oh just try it try it
[ __ ]
damn it damn it stop twitching it's so
weird
damn kick what can I hit you there we go
huh huh huh damn it
cuz they take like knowing like ten hits
to kill even when I'm on like a car or
something I can't believe I'm doing this
ah ah damn it
uh-huh damn it uh-huh damn it all right
no that's good
ah [ __ ] hell all right Oh get back
get back get back
ah ah ah dammit ah I'm fine [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] I am
oh come on [ __ ] are you what the hell
[ __ ] ow
yo yo gosh gosh golly darn it those guys
are tough
jiminy Christmas please where all the
little ones let's take a little trip
down revolver lane oh you too
oh hello how about all I got I gotta
make sure I nail these shots cuz I can't
waste this gun ammo boom yeah another
one down oh hello
nope okay cool got swing long like a
mouse it's amazing how he can fit all
those bullets on his thumb it's really
really incredible what he's breakable
yes they are
oh my god yes they are oh there's gonna
be a head hand in here I'm breaking your
[ __ ] lady that looks like a what are you
joking me hahaha
there was fire damage from oh my god
from just standing on those candles okay
that was that was just silly all right
lady you won that round
ah
oh wow Oh what hey you're wearing a
sweater like me oh ah damn it
hmm come at me bro come at me dumb there
you don't matter
both it once and don't care so pro at
this game huh I could just jump up here
I suppose
got ya [ __ ] come here thank you
whoop hello come ooh you twist your head
you you do - she'd consume you
you could whack ha ha ho miss me oh yeah
whack whoops whack ah damn it
you son of AB you you attack quick ah
sigh step sighs yep sidestep ah you're
tough sides yeah there we go
I got him I got him dead window smash no
it's locked
huh huh just some invincible invisible
guy hmm
screw that screw that [ __ ]
hey I want to try something okay give me
I'm in my box
ah see you I killed you
oh maybe I just unleashed an unnatural
horror pop pills okay those worth it
I just heard something was like under
stairs nothing never anything under the
stairs
whoo these pictures are weird Oh head
hand damn it [ __ ] you
ah come on
[ __ ] you there you are I see you oh
there's more than one all right here
those guys anymore no okay good good ah
come here bro whoa you're a fast one
you're really fast
come here okay I'll help out the railing
I'll hop on the I can hop on the railing
there we go Kalu closer closer no no no
come on don't be shy don't be shy come
here there we go that's oh come on come
back here do I need a shotgun your face
off
do I boom see point-blank boom there we
go all right I'm trying to be more
conservative with ammo but I guess it's
okay if I shoot you know some sometimes
ha ha I see you see you
come at me bro oh yeah right there
that's good stay stay stay stay
man come on your turn
who's next yeah you the sex does have oh
god it's talking my ass off and blah
blah blah
not even caring about where I was come
here come here come here come here come
here come on
I can't Rach oh there we all I can he's
gonna like close the gap ah there see ah
but I was ready for you that time wasn't
talking to my beautiful fans there gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme
there we are alright I am saving quite a
bit of ammo which I'm proud of maybe in
there ah yes more could see it but it
was there oh those are the slowest
opening cabinet doors there is as if
something is going to happen like can
the conic ah
oh no it's one of those big giant heads
oh oh okay where is he worried sorry why
are you
i seea ah oh it's like the model of the
grande oh I saw like a faint outline Oh
in it ah ah not again ah [ __ ] you know I
can do better I can do better
oh yeah huh huh yes
got ya [ __ ] anything back here no
what's the point of coming up you all I
see and that did what did that did no
but it did some effective use of the
revolver it's really nice having ammo
sometimes III guess they were expecting
me to like in the beginning of the game
to fight a lot more things with the
knife but the knife was the wimpiest
thing ever it would have taken like whoa
I see you up there
can't get me I miss sorry ah ah go back
go back
yes yeah just in time and more ammo oh
that's more artful than disturbing I
like that one
oh what's that you be for 15 16 17
oh no it's just 12 13 14 15 16
pills yes over 50 LPN by way of many
many safe states like the ring okay so
the red button did something I don't
know maybe it opened the daemon door oh
it open yeah I made it
ha what invisible is their key oh all
the [ __ ] fire oh I see it it's brown
daemon key anybody out there okay that's
all the time I got for this episode
thank you guys so much for watching
we'll leave you with this nice picture
this lady here so thanks again everyone
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next part bye bye